well there's a national day for
everything right and today marks
international carrot day but the best
way to celebrate is with carrot cake of
course so we called in our friends from
dw bistro we have bryce and dalton to
show us how the dessert is done right
how are you guys welcome back yes okay
before we even get into any of this we
were talking before the show we're
talking about grammys and you said that
um a grammy award winner has actually
eaten this exact cake oh yeah we have
fed miss patti labelle
we actually met her back in 2003 we
worked the grammys in l.a it was really
nice to have vegas have the grammys here
but yeah she has been a frequenter of
the restaurant over the years we've fed
her when she's done shows here in vegas
louise also brought her food yep oh my
god she loves our carrot cake so we also
fed lisa vanderpump carrot cake she
loves it and our uh our late senator
harry reid and his wife landra we
actually
overnighted a carrot cake to washington
dc for their thanksgiving ones okay so
this must be the best
on the planet and you guys have given me
a glove yeah yeah we're going to make it
work so this is so this is a nice little
trick this is how we do it right now
this is made in this mold so it's this
is what this is don't throw this part
away this is the lickety party
because one of the things that makes is
a tropical carrot cake besides all the
lovely ingredients and there's macadamia
nuts there's carrots there's ginger
there's coconut but we use a mango sauce
on the plate so you can go ahead and
decorate an artist performed
so chef dalton will tell you so at the
restaurant we decorate the bottom of the
plate before we actually put that okay
like a little squiggle there you go
perfect that's the way you did that
perfect look at that oh
and then on the top of the carrot cake
we do a little bit of a
strawberry like that yes the very
situation is looking good we've sold
probably like i don't know 3 000 carrot
cakes in our existence we're celebrating
our 12th anniversary congratulations you
guys are obviously doing yours in the
restaurant business and um we're missing
those uh the mimosas right here you guys
are known for that but
we're talking all about the carrot cake
and just a quick question for you
because a carrot cake isn't just carrot
what makes it delicious and special well
we have delicious pineapple in there we
have coconut in there we have some
ginger in there the coconut cream cheese
frosting is also the kicker when we
first started making this i told dalton
absolutely to test carrot cake yes and
it's this one is more like a spice cake
with carrots in it
so it's not like when you think about
you know when you're a kid i didn't like
zucchini bread carrot cake that sounded
so silly but really this has been a home
run since day one well bryce dalton you
guys really know how to say i need a
fork i'm about to do yeah i don't know
oh yeah see
well be sure to go visit dwb i hang out
there a lot so trust me the food is good
the drinks are good go visit them
they're at the grammar see you happy
thank you thank you so much
i want the lickety thing yeah